I should actually say dick was kind of
like a second advisor to me and he was
very generous with this time and I would
go and chat with him a lot so I kind of
feel like I I was a student as well and
yeah one of the nice things about events
like this is it's a little bit like you
know also your relationship to your
parents you know as you get through life
and have kids of your own and so on you
have a new perspective on what you learn
from your parents and it's kind of
similar with advisors as well okay so
that over there is a young dick carp and
it's about back to back to the future
going beyond worst-case analysis and
I'll get to to that topic later but let
me start by first reminiscing a little
bit about dick and so I was there from
1992-94 and it's roughly how it looked
like back then and dick I found this
poor and that's roughly how I remember
him at that time and so of course I it
is already 18 years after the discovery
of np-completeness so yeah dick was of
course famous throughout the world but
even so when i got to berkeley i was
amazed how much of a superstar or rock
star he was whenever he would speak on
campus whether teaching or giving
research talks they were huge crowds ok
maybe not sprout plaza but but very huge
crowds and didn't matter what he was
talking about you know so maybe if he
was teaching parallel Aldens ok you
understand that a hundred people want to
to hear about it or maybe communication
complexity well it was somewhat useful
in thinking about VLSI but then I've
also said I also saw a class of 80
computer science grad students sitting
in rapt attention you know these are
programming languages or system students
or whatever through lectures on broome
Minkowski and I think that it's it's
hard to imagine what kind of a rock star
dick was in those days you know that the
students always thought you know if you
want to learn theory you go to dick's
classes and and he had this very dry but
very elegant way of teaching which
I would just sit back in the class you
know what so when I was as ta and just
sort of note and take notes actually
take noise you know how did he manage to
explain that in just a few lines okay so
and then as I said I got the chance to
interact with him a bit and go talk some
research with him and tell him about my
research and one thing that struck me
was that when I would go and talk to him
out would come his yellow legal pad and
pen and you know as I was talking he was
taking notes and and this is a little
bit surprising because you know there
are lots of who are young here and you
know when you are young and you know
especially in a mathematical field
there's as much or attitude right you
tell me something and in two minutes I
know what you're talking about and I
know the rest of the proof or whatever
right everybody wants to be like that
and and here's a great dip the carp and
he's you know pulling out his he was the
only professor who did this you know
take out his yellow legal pad and start
taking notes and following along and and
that really humanized him and it's
something I've I've learned from him you
know that don't try to be this to act as
a smartest person in the room because
you'll probably learn a lot more you
know when you even you act like this
people will tell you more give you more
examples try to explain to you better
and you'll learn a lot more the other
thing I learned and prob occurs talk
captured this very elegantly was that
you know NP completeness is of course
the greatest theory in our field and but
when you actually talked to dick he was
not the one who was interested in the
grand theory it was always you know
concrete problems concrete examples
elegant solutions and provocateurs talk
captured that very well and and that was
also a learning experience you know I
can't say I still fully absorbed it but
it was very striking how you approach
problems and if you look at the kinds of
things he did and again provocator had
many more examples you can see that
playful spirit you know you take a
little problem develop it and then maybe
something will amor
something more generally emerged from it
okay so so but in today's talk i'm
talking about one aspect of DIC which
puzzled me a lot at the time but I've
come to appreciate more and more as i
get older and I start by saying you know
by telling you something that it's a
little bit surprising when you're when
you encounter for the first time so
imagine it's 1972 and you are the carp
and your co-discoverer of
np-completeness which is going to be a
very successful theory and what do you
do next and it's surprising that one of
the akan sirs was to immediately start
looking for alternatives to worst-case
complexity so a famous paper affairs on
the Traveling Salesman problem talks
about a probabilistic analysis of
partitioning algorithms for the TSP when
the points are randomly drawn from the
plane it's a very nice paper which I
rediscovered after I'd left Berkeley em
and when I when I started working on tsp
and the thing of things I've underlined
here is probabilistic analysis so he's
already thinking about you know
performing some unknown worst-case
instances and also he's taking existing
algorithms partitioning algorithms here
are six and trying to analyze them so as
a young person maybe I didn't fully
appreciate you know why dick went that
route and of course he did all kinds of
other things of course after that too
but it was a little puzzling and in fact
that tension has persisted in our field
because there are lots of alternatives
to worst-case random graph model smooth
analysis semi-random 20 graph models
capacity block moles any number of
models but the big theories are in the
worst case realm and things like convex
programming online arms of course these
are all areas that dick has also
contributed to approximation algorithms
PCP theorems uni games conjecture metric
and bearings PPID completeness it's all
about you know what happens on on the
worst case
put and and there's a there's a tension
there that beautiful theory comes from
comes from comes in these voice k
settings and then in the meanwhile there
they are heuristics out there and we've
always known this which are unreasonably
effective and typically whenever I talk
to dick about NP completeness or PCP or
anything sooner or later he'd bring up
the heuristic it always bothered him and
and you know why are these heuristics
that are so unreasonably effective
branch and bound for integer programming
the PLL family force at solving software
verification you know I suppose most
people here know that sad is considered
an easy problem out of the systems
community they solve it on millions of
variables Markov chain Monte Carlo on
counting problems and sharpey belief
propagation with business etc so so we'd
hear a sort of said okay real-life
instance method special structure and I
managed to find one one photo of take
where he's not looking as happy where
you know he would always bring these up
in conversations you know what's missing
why are these problems easier in real
life so um so more recently I became
interested in understanding this
phenomenon machine learning and there
unless if you've been if you've been
away for for the last five years somehow
you will know that there are amazing
results such as deep nets which do at
this which have at this point human
level performance and image recognition
or state of the art in language
translation and all kinds of other
fields which we looked at our community
looked at in the 80s and said oh it's a
very hard crypto hard problem you know
it's going to be very hard but it's
actually solvable on millions of
variables and so that's of course the
latest but even before this is a long
free of successful heuristics and
machine learning
expectation-maximization expected
minimization give sampling alternating
minimization etc so as I said when I
started looking at this I sort of under
starting it began to understand a little
bit better what they had been trying to
say to us do all those years which is
that you know what is the connection of
NP hardness to reality and and so I I'm
not going to say anything very profound
here this is completely follows from the
definition but let me just illustrate
what this question is trying to ask so
so suppose you are trying to understand
reality in some way for instance you're
trying to understand the thematic
structure of New York Times documents
articles so just unsupervised learning
you're trying to you have a corpus of
document and you're trying to understand
this document about politics this
document is about politics and sports
whatever so let's call that one point in
the input space so we are trying to
understand some real life situation okay
but you can replace this with anything
else markets or or the human cell or
anything then somebody makes a
mathematical problem out of it and
that's like putting a bigger circle
around this dot okay so for instance in
this case this mathematical problem may
be called learning topic models okay
I'll return to this in a in a couple of
slides doesn't matter what it is it's a
mathematical problem and it contains a
point you were interested in the reality
and then what does np-hardness mean it
means that some very smart person
thought hard and was able to encode
instances of this larger problem I sorry
imports 3sat NP hard problem as in
instances of this larger problem okay so
now there is a point in that larger
circle which is difficult okay I'm not
saying anything profound this is exact
NP hardness means but this leaves open
the possibility that there's a smaller
circle you could have drawn around this
point which could be tractable okay I'm
not saying anything profound here but
but the thing that start bothering me is
that this larger circle that was drawn
you know learning topic models the
mathematical formulation is a human
construct right it depends upon who
formulated the problem who the advisor
was what whether they had coffee in the
morning all those kinds of things and so
and then to take that as the definition
of reality is a little one should be
careful okay and I think this is what
dick was talking about all you know so
NP hardness is a mathematical theory is
very consistent then beautiful but what
is it what exactly is the connection to
reality and so I don't know about in
general but I've been thinking about
this in machine learning and the reason
for hope in machine learning as opposed
to say sat solving for support for
system verification is that there are
lots of models of what the input looks
like so you can actually do something
like average case or some other kind of
analysis so that's what I've been
engaged in and so I want to comment on
this change in course from hardness to
easiness okay so the point is that if
you draw this circle so there's a point
I want to make that if you draw this
circle very big right it's actually a
more elegant math problem it'll have
fewer definitional items so the bigger
is a circle the more elegant the math
problem but then the easier it is to
prove hardness results okay so so if you
want to change course from going from
hardness to easiness what should you be
doing so in reading one should be you
need to make assumptions okay and and
that'll simplify the problem okay and it
will make the task of the person who in
the hardness result much harder right so
and so I'll use this example of topic
modeling and I
maybe some people have seen my other
talks on this side we just very brief
just a couple slides it's an
unsupervised method you're given
articles in new york times article say
completely unlabeled by humans you're
trying to uncover thematic structure
what does that mean so you discover that
they are say 300 topics ok and then
topic one topic to topic 300 and and
this article is about the fifth topic
and the 10th time ok something like that
and then then a human expert may say
these two hundred topics that you've
identified correspond to politics sports
Middle East or whatever so how do you do
that so how do machine learning people
approach this so the first thing to
realize is that there is a bag of words
assumption ok so they throw away all
linguistic structure which there's
evidence that linguistic structures
syntax doesn't capture meaning so much
this is not so relevant meaning and you
can just look at which words appear in
the document so that's called the bag of
words assumption and so the article is a
bag of words which means that it's just
a vector giving you the word frequencies
how many each word occur in the document
so now it's a so now you turn the
document into a long vector that's very
sparse it is very few non zeros just you
know the 500 words that appeared in it
out of 100,000 words in the dictionary
ok so now the document corpus is a
matrix where the ice column is the
document and this is this matrix of
sparse so what what is this field topic
models do it's a as I said it's there's
a assumption that there's a hidden
variable explanation of this this these
articles and this originated in a paper
of puppet me through Raghavan Tamaki a
impala and then it was developed in the
machine learning community no I
specifically Blige or knowing have a
famous lda model so the idea is that the
document is a mixture of topics ok so
nature has pretty hard at how is nature
produce all the house and York Times
produce it as a mixture using mixture of
topics so you're thinking of New York
Times writers as monkeys which sort of
just
randomly picking topics and producing
documents so for instance they are
nature may have a topic food where
there's a certain probability of
different words occurring like banana
maybe three percent snow may be zero
percent sakwa 0% walnut five percent and
then there might be another topic
whether where the the proportions are
somewhat reverse snow appears but
walnuts doesn't appear and then when
nature wants to produce or New York
Times wants to produce an article it
takes some these mixes matches these
topics you know it takes a few topics
gives them some weightings and then that
gives a new distribution the sum of
distribution is dug in a distribution
and then you sample 500 words from the
distribution and that's your particle
okay so nobody's claiming as I said
we've already lost syntactic structure
nobody's claiming this is all unless if
you are critical the New York Times that
this is how the New York Times produces
their articles but now the question is
okay given that that's the ground truth
how do you recover this ground given the
articles okay so so there's a lot it is
a big area and there are probabilistic
methods what we'd call heuristics
because we don't know convergence proves
to them which try to do this and in some
joint work we came up with a we
identified property of the of the ground
truth that may be useful in solving it
so this is we call separate booty so
separable means that for every topic
there's a word that appears basically in
that topic and none of the other topics
so snow occurs within the weather topic
but not in the food or the soccer topic
so it's called separate booty so for so
for each other 300 topics there's some
word that appears basically in that
topic with good probability and not in
the other topics so that's a very mild
assumption because there are hundred
thousand words in the dictionary ok so
just 300 of them are special which we
call anchor woods so these are anchor
woods we don't know these we don't know
the ground truth but we're trying to
recover it but somehow just that making
this assumption about the ground truth
completely changes the geometry of the
problem so
try to map it too closely you know
there's some sequence of steps I'm
omitting but turns out the mat structure
changes as follows so this is a paper
with wrong girl uncle Roy try and
Rebecca not that so the problem geometry
changes follows so the original problem
is the following that there is a bunch
of points in high-dimensional space non
negative vector so the vectors have non
negative coordinates and you're trying
to find our dimensional simplex so r is
much smaller the number of topics with
non non vertices which also have non
negative coordinates such that the
convex hull this simplex contains all
the points you were given ok so that's
the turns out is there is a mathematical
heart of the problem ok and this is
np-complete because you don't know where
these vortices have to be the vertices
of the simplex ok and we also show that
if are a small like 300 it's fixed
parameter complete so you won't have
better than and to the our algorithms ok
so separate body changes this problems
geometry very dramatically so separate
bility implies that the vertices of the
simplex that you're looking for appear
among the rows of em ok sorry among the
points you're given sorry ok so among
the points that you're given the
vertices of simplex are in there you
just don't know which ones and then
there's a fairly simple convex
programming type procedure that
identifies the voices ok so then using
these ideas you we came up with probably
Ireland topic modeling and then we were
motivated it seems so simple we even
implement hadn't to undergrads implement
it in Python and it beats the pants off
of existing techniques and in statistics
alright so that was that was an example
of how making a simple assumption about
the problem can completely change its
complexity and its geometry and and the
point here to make is that the domain
experts will never be able to tell you
that assumption I could have talked to
they apply my colleague for a week and I
would never come up with this assumption
that he would never said because reality
you know they satisfy so many properties
he wouldn't be able to pinpoint look at
this property another change
the two complexity so it's it's we you
have to do this and we have to be
willing to make assumptions the second
ingredient in this course change from
hardness to easiness is that you have to
understand and exploit the surprising
amount of distribution structure in the
inputs so this was already present in
topic modeling to some extent because
you use the fact that nature you know
our new york times article writers are
monkeys randomly picking proportions of
topics and so on that's already used but
but what a point i want to make is that
actually there is surprising amount of
distributional structure okay and it's
it's continues to surprise me and
there's very little theory for this
distribution structure in machine
learning because that's not you know
people fit things they they develop
procedures to uncover structure but
they're very little theories of how the
structure arises so the example that
uses word embeddings to capture word
meanings which are useful in all kinds
of natural language processing tasks and
these look kind of a little scary when
you first see them you know that words
have you know so many shades of meaning
you captured by vector like a
three-dimensional vector that's called a
wooden Bay okay and you can do all kinds
of tasks involving meanings of words
semantics using this vector so so let me
say a little bit more about how these
vectors arise okay so empirically so
then many methods so here's one method
use what's called the PMI matrix so let
pw w prime be the probability the
empirical probability that words w and w
prime occur next to each other in a
corpus so you take a large corpus
Wikipedia New York Times billion words
sorry length billion and you look at the
empirical probability 0 WN w prime occur
next to each other or say within
distance five of each other in the
corpus and PF w is the probability of W
occurring in the corpus how many times
appears there's something called PMI
pairwise mutual information which is a
measure of correlation but it's highly
nonlinear
so you take so in the measure of
correlation is you take the joint
probability P WWI the pw w prime and
divided by the product of the marginals
so that's some kind of correlation
measure because you know how much is a
joint probability bigger or smaller than
the product of the individual problems
so that's the measure right the the the
ratio of the joint probability divided
by the product of probabilities but then
you take a look so it's nonlinear highly
nonlinear so as a function of the input
is highly nonlinear so it's called
pointwise mutual information and now you
look at the PMI matrix this hundred
thousand one hundred thousand matrix all
the words in the dictionary where the
WWF I'm entry is the PMI value and you
have to do something special for those
where this thing is zero so but look at
you define a matrix so this is one
hundred thousand hundred thousand matrix
and the surprising empirical fact is
that it turns out to be fairly low
dimensional approximately so impaired
plates well approximated by Laurent
matrices okay so this is a phenomenon
that occurs in word embeddings that word
co-occurrences there's some nonlinear
function of those and then those turn
out to be explainable by some low
dimensional explanation so these then
you can factor that matrix approximately
and get some water matting that's
roughly the idea going on people have
used deep nets and all kinds of other
models but that's the intuition okay
that's a good first step to understand
intuition so the question is why why is
this what is it about language that that
causes matrix to be low dimensional now
surprisingly you would imagine that you
know people have had these methods for
30 years that somebody would have asked
that question but apparently nobody have
so we gave a generator model which
actually derives this as a you know
something like topic models but it's
log-linear so it's a generator model and
it predicts this many other relationship
scene makes also all kinds of other
predictions our analysis which then you
know I are supposed ought to implement
and those also hold true for the data so
you make some predictions that analysis
predicts some things about the data
which actually turned out to be true and
so the AI it explains various things
about what emetics but the point I was
making was that there's a lot of
structure in the in the world and it's
not just that you're given a matrix
about the world and then you do whatever
with the matrix the matrix has structure
you have to understand matrix okay so in
the last slide I just want to make some
suggestions for further developing this
kind of area and and and this is also
suggesting for paper referees because
you know when you start doing this kind
of work and you send papers to stop
folks you get some crazy reviews back so
which is okay which is okay you know so
sorry yeah I understand this is this is
not the first time yeah so so anyway so
this is just clarifying some issues okay
that paper with that you should be aware
of so let's go back to this picture
right the the bigger circle you draw the
easier it is to prove a hardness result
right and the bigger circle corresponds
to the fewest assumptions the smaller
circle corresponds to more assumptions
right if you want to prove if you want
to make the task of improving NP
hardness results more difficult you have
to go for the smaller circle right so if
we want to actually solve problems that
arise in the real world we have to go to
the smaller circle so so beware the
minimum description length aesthetic ok
so that the shorter the fewest
assumptions is the best theorem ok so so
this is this you have to make the fewest
number of assumptions but has to lead to
it easiness result ok so so it's a right
so so long as we really have this
aesthetic of the fewest assumptions will
end up in audience ok and then maybe we
are not capturing we are you so well the
second suggestion is to combine mat with
modeling ability that you have to be
able to look at the situation and make
assumptions or make models or explain
models etc it's more like physics and
econ it's less like pure math again
there are many people here who pioneered
this kind of work before and lastly be
wary of tools that make noise
options so like Johnson and minstrels
dimension eruption okay applies to all
set of points and you know it then gives
you weak results right login where
epsilon square is not that much less
than N or M reddy's regularity lemma you
make no assumption of the graph and you
get some result that only applies to
graphs that don't even fit in the
universe so it's just something to be
aware of ok so again yeah beware of the
minimum description length aesthetic so
I'll and on that note thank you so much
stick I as I said you know some of the
lessons he taught me I only slowly
appreciate as I get older and I really
saw this picture which those of you know
they remember his his very cradle map
gesture and I was very happy that
somebody some photographer somewheres
capture it thank you yes as a field so
depends right so if you want an
algorithm make the minimus minimum or
assumptions to get to the algorithm yeah
that's still that's the holes but yeah